in this episode I'm going to show you
four different ways to share data
between angular components parent to
child
via the input decorator when you declare
a variable with the input decorator in
the child component it allows that
variable to be received from the parent
component template in this case we
define a message variable in the parent
then use square brackets to pass the
data to the child now the child
component can display the data in its
own template
[Music]
child to parent via output and event
emitter another way to share data is to
omit it from the child which can be
listened to by the parent this
approaches ideal when you want to share
data changes that occur on things like
button clicks form entries and other
user events in the child we declare a
message of that variable with the output
decorator and set it equal to a new
event emitter then we create a function
named send message that calls emit on
this event with the message we want to
send
lastly we create a button to trigger
this function in the HTML
[Music]
in the parent we create a function to
receive the message and set it equal to
the message variable the parent can now
subscribe to this message event that's
outputted by the child component then
run the receive message function
whenever that event occurs child to
parent via view child view child allows
one component to be injected into
another giving the parent access to all
of its attributes and functions when
caveat however is that the child won't
be available until after the view is
fully initialized this means we need to
implement the after view in it lifecycle
hook to receive the data from the child
[Music]
inside the after view and it function we
can then access the message variable
that was defined inside the child
component share data between any
unrelated components when passing data
between components that lack a direct
connection such as siblings
grandchildren etc you should use a
shared service when you have data that
always needs to be insane I find that
the rxjs behavior subject is very useful
in this situation the main benefit of a
behavior subject is that it ensures
every component consuming the service
receives the most recent up-to-date data
in the service we create a private
behavior subject that will hold the
current value of the message then we
define a current message variable set to
an observable it will be used by the
components
lastly we create a function that calls
next on the behavior subject to change
its current value
[Music]
the parent-child and sibling components
all receive the same treatment we inject
the service in the constructor then
subscribe to the current message
observable and set its value equal to
the message variable now we can create a
function in any one of these components
that changes the value of the message
when this function is executed the new
data will automatically be broadcast to
all their components
[Music]
that's it for data sharing see you next
time
[Music]